hello there
myth chasers it's been a while since we
last looked over your myths and theories
in the ever-changing world of fortnite
battle royale if you have a burning
question or a quest for us
pop it in the comments below and slap a
like on those you want to be tested next
episode
this week wolverine arrived in fortnite
so if you'd be so kind to use adamaru as
your supporter creator code
let's chase and potentially bust a few
myths
before we introduce wolverine to our
myths i read this myth
and it's brilliant as we all know
stark's bots will rez him if he's
knocked around stark industries
but bemfot asks will the other bots at
the far side of the island revive mr
stark
told you it was a good one so our task
is to get tony stark
all the way to the quinjet by the broken
castle to see if he will be rezzed by
his bots
and to see what he does next the first
thing we noticed is that even with a
chopper
stark pops on the way to the chosen
location so we needed a detailed plan
for this
while my teammates knocked iron man and
got him on the chopper
i went to nearby campsites and made room
for health regen
runs leaving wood near the campfire to
help them burn
and then waited at sweaty sands for the
lads to drop in and top off
and then there was no stopping us the
moment of truth will stark's bots
revive their daddy
[Music]
hell yeah look at that tony stark is
back up and running and immediately
runs all the way back home by the way if
you're wondering why we jumped out of
the chopper at a crazy height
it's so that the bots don't go into rage
mode and instead
prioritize getting tony back on his feet
tony will run
all the way back to stark industries if
left completely alone
but he gets completely stuck and sorta
just stands here
all depressed poor guy cheer up tony i
love you three thousand
still too soon for that joke my bad
let's bring logan to this party
wolverine is here he's found lurking in
weeping woods hunting for a fight
and when he gets our scent there is no
stopping him
which leads to our next myth what
happens when wolverine
and dr doom meet a very nice easy one
right
well in standard games this can be
difficult as wolverine is so overpowered
we are eliminated before we know it the
trick with wolverine is to get him to
chase us
inside a vehicle the extra speed can
keep him at bay
we made it all the way to doom's domain
and wolverine did not disappoint
he went on the warpath until he found
doctor doom
here's what happened well he sort of
just stood there looking
at doom for a while and we actually had
to nudge him in manually
to get this show on the road doom does
get some big hits in
but when wolverine goes to town he
always comes out victorious
it certainly looks like wolverine is the
strongest boss in fortnite history
which leads to our next myth
iron man will take down wolverine at
stark industries
i like this myth and i like the guy's
name well played tony stank
as we all know wolverine will follow us
anywhere on the island
so we jumped into fortnite but this time
use battle lab so anybody can try this
one out
on the plus side this means we could be
killed multiple times on the bad side
bosses won't get knocked in this form
but anyway here's a time lapse of us
trying our best to get weapon x
all the way to stark industries it took
forever it really did
we died many times but once we got him
there and both bosses saw one another
the action started here's what happened
wow wow not even close tony stark had
zero chance at all
and neither did any of his bots
wolverine is so op
we'll try this again as soon as another
boss is added to the game
next myth please sarah reba says
myth what happens when iron man and
doctor doom meet each other
this one is super simple but also the
hardest to make work
there is seemingly no way to get stark
to doom or vice versa without knocking
one down
here's the best we did remember the bot
rest technique from earlier
in which stark is picked up anywhere on
the island as long as a bot is near
well we used this strat to get tony to
walk as close to doom's domain as
possible
the plan was simple use shock waves and
crash mats to push him into the poi
but it was so painful to say the least
stark would stop for no reason
he'd change direction without warning
he'd even swim in the river for a few
minutes
i personally think he was taking a leak
and then the storm rolled in and he
wouldn't move at
all however we tried we couldn't get
stark into doom's domain
so this myth isn't busted or chased this
is still open-ended this one is for you
guys
can you get stark to doom without
knocking any of them and if you're
wondering this is what
happens when you take a knocked iron man
to doom's domain
wow i suppose i should have expected
that
[Music]
oh here's a really good one cody munding
says
myth mystique can become a husk after
killing one and using her remote
oh i like this one okay right now there
are no husks or fiends in battle royale
so this one is a save the world question
i likey
so i jumped into the pve mode and chose
mystique and her shape-shifting emote
then i shot a zombie and tried to mimic
them
[Music]
sadly this is a busted myth to be sure i
tried this multiple times
no positive results mystique's
shapeshifter emote does not work
and save the world rip the dream
and now are you ready for the best myth
of 2020
check this out sega dreamcast says
the ghost and shadow henchmen can defeat
wolverine
i know what you're thinking right now
this is impossible this is stupid maybe
if tony stark and dr doom can't take on
wolverine
how on earth can two former henchmen do
it
well to you i say watch this if you
don't know about the greatest bromance
in history let me update you quickly
at the start of season 4 two henchmen
from the old ghost and shadow factions
found each other and instead of warring
they decided to become
friends they danced the days away at the
local gas station before getting a room
at the hotel in lazy lake
it's a fragile truce i admit but it's
becoming stronger every week in chapter
two
and now we're gonna lead a self-healing
maniac like wolverine over there
i'm sorry in advance here we go the
journey over using a vehicle
is far easier than i expected as long as
wolverine can be kept at bay
a few minutes later and we've arrived at
lazy lake and we've got wolverine close
enough to the two henchmen
the shadow dude doesn't want any part of
this but the ghost henchmen
was all over wolverine with aim like a
stormtrooper
over the next 10 minutes they fought
[Music]
[Music]
until it finally happened the henchman
beat wolverine
in a heads-up fight what a moment in
history
a new boss has arrived
during the scuffle the shadow henchmen
actually did come to life
and tried to take out the ghost henchmen
we didn't allow that
but let's go further into this like with
all our myths we check them twice to
make sure they're fully tested
and this is what went down the second
time all three men were trapped in the
basement of the hotel
and both ghost and shadow teamed up to
take down weapon x
teamwork makes the dream work let's
ignore the fact that they uh started
fighting each other straight afterwards
the news here is that the toughest sobs
in fortnite right now
are the henchmen my mind is blown this
is why i love myth chaser videos
before we go i have one last myth for
you and it's from irebios
sorry if i'm saying that wrong who says
what happens when wolverine goes into a
rift
what glider does he use a perfect myth
to end thanks to battle labs this is a
far easier myth than it would be in a
typical squads match
a simple chase and then a bait and
switch and now wolverine
is heading into that rift
and there it is wolverine does indeed
have a glider
another thing to note is that wolverine
will actually use his glider to get back
home
he doesn't just go straight down like
the other bosses do he's going back to
weeping wood to wherever he is
he likes it there so there we have it a
good episode if i do say so myself
gotta love those henchmen on screen are
the names that i've been trying to thank
for
two weeks now sorry it's taken me so
long but here you go thank you so much
for using code adamaru and supporting me
i'll be back in my dms later this week
to thank more of you awesome people
in person i'm adam from playstation
grenade you're awesome stay that way
i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you